[Music]
it's the new year which around here
means it's time for new dragons coming
from new baby dragons people who fly
with babies are the worst body break no
super huge dragons new never-before-seen
dragons he's not the only one he's a
light fury
did she just disappear and a brand new
hidden world of well you guessed it
dragons we get it the world's first
dragon Viking utopia Julie don't be on
maybe Mike's less clothes added more Oh
sanitary DreamWorks How to Train Your
Dragon the hidden world I guess you have
no so bad after all this is Berk son it
was the home of your grandparents and
their grandparents before then but out
there beyond the age of the water why is
the home of the Dragons
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you do know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up
he's not the only one
[Music]
another night Furies more like a right a
Night Fury
yeah yours is better probably there is
an armada with enough cages for all of
our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy
we need to find the hidden world I will
destroy everything you realize
you're nothing without your dragon if
Grimaud succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up game
you brought a baby to a battle I
couldn't find a sitter
the hidden worlds have really touched
the key
right but inside
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]
[Music]